is there any way to kind of address this
is there anything that we could do as
people to bring awareness to this is
there any way there could be some kind
of Peace here well the trend lines are
coming in my direction when it comes to
public perception on this I mean
initially like the American people were
dying to send every American dollar you
know to Ukraine and increasingly at
least within the Republican Party you've
started to see that shift as our
economic conditions are more in the
Forefront of people's minds like we have
laws that require end-to-end monitoring
of materiel when we send it into a war
zone and
I am not convinced We are following this
is it because we're not technically at
War the United States hasn't been
technically at a war since World War II
well in a we do have regs that Define a
conflict Zone and whenever we send stuff
that kills into one of those places
we're supposed to know who has it and we
don't and that is concerning to me if
that's like the new thing is like oh
well you know send the stuff anything
what was it that Ben sass said when he
was in the Senate if it shoots send it
and so we've been doing all of that and
I think that in some ways prolongs
conflict it doesn't bring us to a faster
resolution to continue to pour cash and
weapons into a historically corrupt
country that is fighting yeah Dave Smith
would say and has said if you want to
see who our next big enemy is going to
be look at who we're funding right now
and I'm concerned that the the knots I
don't know if they're technically are
they considered Nazis let's be uh what
is it Democrats thought so I mean you
had you had uh dozens of Democrats
signing letters saying that the azov
Battalion were a bunch of white
supremacists and while they want to call
our own military who are patriots a
bunch of white supremacists here they
got no problem draining the resources of
our country to go and fund who they were
just calling white supremacists you know
like a couple years ago so if in six
years the azov start Exterminating a
race because they are happen to be
genocidal or racist like then what is
the American you're going to use that as
evidence to go to war in Ukraine to
fight the azov and now we've got a more
military bases in Ukraine protecting the
Suez Canal yep well there's a lot of
Intel reports of a lot of uh Advanced
U.S military hardware being sold on the
black markets as well and a lot of the
weapons even according to CBS News and
Aid not making it to its official
destination and I think that's that's
that's such a travesty because there's
so much human suffering in that country
there's so many people use this pawns
there's so many people hurt with this
larger conflict there's such a bigger
immigration crisis here how do you see
all of this going because you have a lot
of you know uh you're in Congress you
talk to a lot of people there how do you
see this kind of unfolding here with
this never-ending War where where are we
going to be a couple years from now with
this continuing the way it is what
worries me is like you cannot overstate
the gravity of some of the worst
potential outcome sets here I mean you
know Russia much like a bond villain
sort of becomes more and more dangerous
during its demise it's it's a
kleptocracy in a lot of ways I mean a
lot of people have gotten out of Russia
with whatever they could steal on their
way out right to your point about the
material in the black market and so I
think that for us to go and like play a
game of nuclear chicken over which guy
in a track suit gets to run Crimea is
foolish and it's not it's not how
serious a serious country ought to
behave you think World War III could
result from recklessness of course of
course this is a Tinder Box and it's not
Syria right it's Russia and Ukraine it
is a country that has enough nuclear
power to end Earth multiple times over
and it's a leader who I don't think is
making stable rational decisions in
Vladimir Putin and you know to continue
to send the high Mars there to send the
Bradleys there from the United States
see seems provocative to me now why
isn't this Europe's problem right you
would think that Germany and the other
powers in Europe would have the most at
stake but what they do you know as these
European Democracies face elections and
as their reserves go down like you're
going to see them
have a different posture towards Russia
as their mandates expire and as they
have to go back for elections plus they
rely on us for a defense right well I
mean we're that was one of the principal
critiques that Trump made that I think
got a lot of disaffected people to
support him is when he said we're I'm
just tired of being like dead money at
the world stage like being the world's
policeman being the world's piggy bank
has not been good for the American
middle class yeah Trump also made sure
that he sent lethal weapons to Ukraine
something Obama was even afraid to do so
I mean this conflict has been brewing
for so long since 2014 even before that
with their Kind of Revolution that's
happening there but it's to me this is
just such such a sad thing to see
Humanity go through
um but um
I I don't know I I just I just hope this
kind of end somehow I don't think it is
I don't know if we should potentially
even change what do you think when you
see your leaders in Congress where the
like American flag Ukraine flag like pin
around wasn't McCarthy doing that yep I
saw a photo I don't know if it was real
it seems like they don't understand that
Russia needs a warm water or wants a
warm water Port into Black Sea like if
that if that was understood and it's
like yo this is about trade this is
about Russia yeah you think it's just a
real estate play yeah do you think he
takes the energy gas problem natural gas
Etc it's real estate yeah I think it is
100 real estate and I don't know why
there's not more American English media
Putin talking real estate but energy
right so yeah Transportation Control is
a large portion of the natural gas from
Russia into into Europe Western power to
the Suez Canal which is all of the
Indian Ocean and things like that put
some weights on Russia Russia doesn't
like it Russia says we're going to go
and take the port back
more so that's what I think is that
they're missing it that they just don't
that they're emotionally uh blockade
their their perception is being
blockaded by emotions because it's
always horrible to see someone get
killed or to see a house get blown up or
Invasion or anything that's horrible you
know I'm against War you know I mean I I
think that it's one of the reasons why
I'm a little more dovish in My Views I I
think oftentimes both sides lose
yeah I I wonder if like you know the
world economic Forum Davos group types
have um substantial influence when it
comes to the wars we declare
have you been uh yeah why is that an
open question in your mind no I think
they do well of course what I mean is to
what degree right
because obviously the goals they have
the actions we take align with them so
it's it's like the US has no reason to
be involved in Ukraine like you said
it's Europe's problem yet for some
reason we're acting like one body yeah
we're the we're the military arm of the
liberal economic order the British
Empire basically have you been asked
that turned out well yeah have you been
asked to be a part of the world economic
forum and what kind of influence do you
think they kind of have on uh the United
States since Klaus Schwab openly brags
about how he has half of the Canadian
Parliament being young members of the
world economic Forum yeah no I I think
that that it's part of the like
political industrial complex it's the
finance wing of the political industrial
complex and so like if what you need to
keep your power and to win your
elections is a Super PAC that shows up
with you know 10 million dollars in dark
money like who do you think Cuts those
checks
you think it's like some guy who's like
a Furniture tycoon in Oklahoma it's not
bang for international settlement and
everybody knows it and everybody knows
and like you know this is an area where
the populist right and the populace left
need to work together on the way that we
fund campaigns in this country because
it like it always works to the benefit
of the uni party and I don't get why
people should be able to put unlimited
money without disclosure into
manipulating the viewpoints of Americans
do you think politically there's going
to be some kind of Rift and change here
because there does seem to be obviously
the the Democrats and the Republicans
but there also seems to be a bigger Rift
amongst the establishment and the
anti-establishment totally uh there's a
lot of populists there's also a lot of
Statistics there's a lot of rhinos
there's a lot of neocons it's like a
civil war within the Civil War within
the Civil War politically speaking not
violently speaking
um do you see the political landscape
changing in the future because I I think
a lot of people are sick of these
neocons of these kind of rhinos and they
don't really represent the American
people we had enough of George W bush he
had his time he ruined that time and I
think he spurred uh uh you know a
situation where now the Democrats have a
lot of power you know when I first got
elected to congress we could have a lot
of collaboration between the populist
right and the populace left on things
like War Powers the surveillance State
um political reforms that don't just
Empower kind of the pack structure
and then January 6 happened and like
those populist leftists like would not
talk to us I mean would not collaborate
with us on bills would not engage in any
way and it became so it became such a
point of personal trauma for some of
them and I don't think that was good for
the country I don't think that was good
for kind of the anti-establishment unity
that we need I will say that like since
Republicans took the majority they've uh
they've been a lot nicer to us dude but
we saw you uh talking with AOC during
this whole process right was that was
that something relevant or that you can
share sure I mean and I I got caught on
camera and conversations with AOC ilhan
Omar and pramila jayapal like three
people who
folks have seen me disagree with more
than agree with with AOC I was
discussing whether or not the Democrats
were going to leave the floor and cut a
deal with McCarthy because that would
have changed the math on the speaker
vote
and so she was actually doing everything
possible to make sure that they didn't
and that there were 212 Democrats voting
for Jeffries on every ballot wow with
jayapal we've worked together on
legislation to break up big Tech and I
was talking to her about the prospects
in a republican Congress and a
republican House of getting some
bipartisan bicameral solutions to
reshape a lot of these companies and the
job legislation from the 117th Congress
like was not you know taking immunities
away and all that it said no like
meta has to alienate their Instagram
asset Google has to alienate email from
search and like literally breaking up
these companies and then with Omar we
were actually talking about War Powers
and wow I was I was teasing her a bit
like I was like you guys like showed up
here and said the military was racist
and like before before you were done
being in the majority you were like
voting for NATO okay you know what what
went what went on there and so I was a I
was a teasing well what did go on there
hypocrisy
you know metabolism I think that they
um they got drafted into that
establishment Democrat thinking yeah I
don't think that the squad really
believes that like NATO is advancing the
interests of their constituents on a day
in day out basis but yet they were still
willing to vote for all these like NATO
strengthening Endeavors well there's oh
God are there some issues that could
Bridge the the kind of populists left in
the populist rights together are there
some things that we could actually agree
upon that could bring this country back
together the first thing that comes to
mind personally is the Epstein Scandal I
think everyone on the left and right
agrees in that but are there some issues
that you think could uh could you guys
could work how about abolishing fisa
right I mean why wouldn't the populist
writing populist left agree to take down
some elements of the surveillance state
yeah absolutely another idea would be
cleaning up the environment like the
atmosphere pulling carbon out of the
atmosphere you can convert it into
graphene or you know here we go everyone
drink correctly no I'm all about the
carbon capture stuff and also this is a
part of like the libertarian thing that
I don't get like why would we
As Americans give carte blanche to a
bunch of powerful businesses to pollute
our air and our water uh to me America
First means that you actually have to
want this to be a beautiful place and
and so I do think that like making sure
that we don't completely sell out to
people to to trash our nation it would
be important regarding using um the
government to protect us from
corporations you were talking about
breaking up big Tech earlier I think a
mistake that we should not make is what
they did to Rockefeller with his
Standard Oil they broke it up into like
seven or eight oil companies and then he
made more money off of these new so like
breaking up Facebook into Facebook Prime
Facebook Messenger Instagram there's
different companies mark would still
have the code he'd still be able to run
software like that so I'm thinking we
need to make them free their software
code so that other people can spin up
versions of those websites interlock
them my version of Facebook can
interoperate with your with Mark
Zuckerberg's version and that was
centralization I think the
interoperability of data is really what
you're what you're talking about Force
the companies and it's sort of like um
sort of like breaking of Monopoly but
we're not actually breaking the company
apart but where I disagree is giving
your proprietary code up is basically
it's your your ownership your
intellectual property but releasing the
algorithmic code yeah how they
manipulate the public with algorithms I
think is extremely important I think
that's the path for big set of big Tech
to heal the system with big Tech as
opposed to trying to smash up companies
and make them do what the government
says they have to do like let them ban
whoever they want but if they're not if
they have bad terms of service and your
version of the site has better terms of
service they're going to lose you well
yeah go ahead no I got I got a different
question so no I don't know about you
but I think uh big Tech had a huge
influence in this latest midterm
election I think they're also
essentially controlling what a lot of
people see and think with their
algorithms they're becoming a huge
powerful entity that of course also now
we're finding out through the Twitter
files work for the private intelligence
agencies that curation that ability to
to control what people see and listen to
that's a huge power I personally think
it had an effect on the election and I
think it's going to continue to have
bigger effects on the election
especially in places that took a lot of
the Zucker bucks Florida was one of the
states that refused money from Facebook
and Mark Zuckerberg and their elections
went totally different than a lot of
states that did is there a solution to
this is there a way to kind of rein in
these intelligence agencies that are
controlling big Tech that are
essentially asserting their will on
everyone else
I think that on the election front the
specific algorithmic work to Target
certain types of Voters to push
registration to push vote by mail to
push early voting to do election day
awareness like that is that is partisan
based on who they are trying to Target
those messages to right and that should
be transparent and if it was transparent
I actually think the right enforcement
tool is the federal elections Commission
because you know when a when Facebook
says okay well like we're going to
Target this exact population of people
with this age range in this ZIP code
that is a donation to a political party
and a political movement and should be
subject to the same caps that any other
American would be subject to I got a
question for the audience
DeSantis Gates 2024 I'm for Trump yeah
I'm for Trump I I think the world of
DeSantis I Trump Gates 2024. well uh I
would do anything the president asked
but I think he's got better choices I
like what I'm what I'm doing now you
know I was very involved into Santa's
first campaign I was his transition
chairman when he came into the
governorship in Florida I helped him
hire a lot of the folks that shape the
policy that make Florida the Envy of the
country right now I think Ron DeSantis
will be president one day but in 2024
it's uh My Hope and expectation will be
Donald Trump thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time